why do I always feel like such a bag of
crap when I fly home for the holidays
it's like I'm getting ready for a war
against a bunch of old nice people why
does their house always smell like
boredom if they put that little smiley
face made out of raisins on my pancakes
I'm gonna freak them out I'll just go up
to my room and put a diaper on be like
you want me to pretend I'm a baby fine
but I got a number two coming in you're
gonna have to change me what is wrong
with me they're just trying to be nice
then they're gonna ask when are you
gonna have grandkids sorry mom my penis
fell off yeah it was weird happened at
the laundromat
doctor says it's hereditary so it's your
fault then one of their friends is gonna
ask me what I've been doing with my life
what since I was 10 I swear you could be
the President of the United States but
if it's 2:00 a.m. and you're lying awake
in your childhood bed you'd still feel
like you accomplished nothing why does
that happen oh crap I forgot my phone
charger it's like my umbilical cord to
my real life oh man and Wi-Fi is gonna
suck why can't they get that to work and
the password is gonna be written on some
tiny scrap of paper somewhere and
everyone's gonna have to look forward
for like two hours shouting across the
room he needs the password
if the plane went down right now I
wonder if they'd still do the dinner
I wonder who would be the saddest and is
so messed up oh and I forgot about
Scrabble can't we all just play words
with friends in our own separate rooms
this year all right stop it stop being
so damn negative maybe this year the
airline can lose all that baggage that I
always bring home with me let me be
thankful this year thankful for these
lovely weird people that can piss me off
more than anyone else in the world and
thankful that I still have them to come
home to
[Music]